hey everyone i am very excited to be
giving my first in-person talk in almost
two years
so today i want to share with you some
of my recent work around how do we get
like hci
human computer interaction professionals
and ai engineers to sort of
collaboratively design human ai
experiences
so if you think about it in the last 20
years or so we've gotten a lot better at
incorporating human centered design
within software engineering workflows
not not ai but like regular
software engineering we've created new
roles uh expertise develop tools and
design processes to kind of really drive
software design based on human needs
user experience designers who are kind
of trained at understanding human
behavior and usability and designing
graphical user interfaces they usually
work with end users to identify their
goals and needs and challenges
these designers then create software
design solutions to address those
needs and challenges and hand them off
to engineers who are experts at writing
software code
to make it a bit more concrete let's
imagine designing a phone unlock user
experience by taking a human-centered
approach it's a very simple example that
kind of
helps you understand the message so if
you are a designer you would first try
to identify when where and how people
are using their phones and what their
security concerns are you will then
derive a set of design needs like you
know the user experience should be like
quick to unlock and it should require
low cognitive effort to remember
you can then prototype a bunch of
interface alternatives such as a numeric
key code an alphanumeric password or a
patent based unlock and we have really
sophisticated prototyping tools that
would allow designers to create these
high-fidelity click-through interactive
prototypes without writing any code
and as a designer you can also like
evaluate these different alternatives
with potential end users and you may
determine that
numeric key code is the best option
at this point as a designer you have
fully defined the user experience to
unlock the phone
including the interface design
interaction behavior style guide the
length of the password and all of that
and you can hand this off to an engineer
who will then build to those
specifications
and over the years we've kind of
optimized this process for efficiency
through things like separation of
concerns and modular design that the
interaction between designers and
engineers is largely that of
coordination and handoff
now imagine designing an ai powered
phone unlock user experience one that
uses facial identification to
authenticate users
the interface design itself is quite
simple and it consists of a blank screen
with a single like a lock icon and such
an interface this i experience has to
support diverse users in varied contexts
of use
now unfortunately unlike conventional
software design designers cannot fully
specify the user experience at the
interface level alone
the design extends beyond the user
interface into the design of different
ai subcomponents as well as in thinking
about the training data
and because ai requires writing meta
programs to learn from data or examples
engineers cannot build software to exact
specifications
which means like the coordination
handoff approach is no longer viable for
designing ai-powered applications
in fact if you look at like recent
literature in the hci community like
they've surfaced a number of challenges
where designers find it really hard to
understand ai capabilities prototyping
ai interfaces is really challenging they
cannot use like this fail fast fail
often approach to prototype api powered
interfaces
the current machine learning workflows
don't really take into account like the
data needs for these machine learning
applications and engineers often treat
data as non-technical
and lastly
engineers and designers have different
priorities and incentives which makes it
really it introduces a lot of friction
for them to collaborate at this
intersection
so in the last couple of years i've been
looking at how might we support
designers and engineers to kind of work
together to co-design these
human-centered ai experiences from the
ground up
and today i'll share with you three
different projects that i've been
working on in answering these questions
the first few are a bit more qualitative
more formative need finding type of work
and then i'll share with you a
prototyping tool that i developed for
designing ai powered applications
yeah so the the the first project is
about um we were looking at how like how
do industry practitioners currently
build human ai systems
now
companies like microsoft google and
apple have been putting out all these
design guidelines for building human ai
applications and ideally these
guidelines represent best practice
advice based on you know current
implementation within these
organizations
so we use these guidelines as a starting
point to kind of understand like you
know how are practitioners you know
putting these guidelines into practice
how are they operationalizing them
within their software design workflows
so we collected a total of 280 design
guidelines and did an affinity
diagramming exercise to kind of identify
what are the key components and tasks
involved in building human ai
applications
the good news is the guidelines do talk
about centering people not just in the
user interface and interaction design
but also
centering them in the design of ai
behavior as well as designing the
training data needs
so
with regard to data these guidelines
prescribe that we consider people when
we're thinking about data needs how we
collect data how we label data as well
as user privacy and security so
an example would be like we should
consider what information would a human
need if they had to perform a task
similarly in terms of ai behavior these
guidelines recommend that we need to
think about people when we are designing
like the ai's behavior
the assumptions and how we implement
those behavior thinking about human
centered ways to measure performance of
these machine learning models evaluating
them with diverse users and thinking
about things like learnability and so on
so
an example would be when designing
automation we should consider if a human
were to perform a task what assumptions
they would make
and lastly these guidelines prescribe
that when we're building these uh ai
experiences we need to think about like
you know what kind of input should we
expect users to provide how should we
present the outputs back to the end user
and how do we integrate ai into human
tasks and also in dealing with ai's
uncertainties like explainability
feedback and failures
so one of the the guidelines talks about
thinking whether to automate or augment
based on how well the ai performs
and across all these layers the goal is
really to see that
we align these experiences with people's
task models that is how they perform the
task today their expectation models
about what they should expect the ai to
do for them or what they expect ai to do
for them and the interaction model or
how they expect to interact with these
ai sub-components
so
using this model as a guide we did an
interview study with 21 industry
practitioners from 14 different
organizations
participants included like software
engineers ux designers product managers
data scientists and research scientists
we recruited them through our network
and then through like snowball sampling
each interview lasted about 60 minutes
and we we coded this data using uh
standard qualitative coding methods in
vivo coding and then we conducted this
memory activity over an extended period
to kind of synthesize the findings
before i talk about the key findings i
just want to give you an overview of
like the organization structures so
within larger organizations you usually
have these core ai research teams who
typically work on like foundational ai
research and coming up with new ai
capabilities and they may also have like
core ux teams and in-house legal and
domain experts
and oftentimes these large organizations
also have these bridge teams who
essentially like take the outputs of
like korea research and create demos and
prototypes for tech transfer to product
teams
so up until this point like you don't
have like product users involved in any
of the decisions that go on here
and then larger organizations have
multiple product teams smaller
organizations may have just one product
team and each product team has typically
has like a manager back in front and
developers as well as ux people
and all of these organizations
work with third-party or external
entities like for smaller organizations
who don't have in-house ai developers
they make use of third-party ai services
but they also like all these
organizations make use of data
annotators university interns as well as
test users
so i'll talk about in the in
the interest of time i'm going to talk
about like two findings from the study
the first is that these the the design
engineering boundary sort of poses
specific challenges to this
cross-disciplinary nature of human ai
design
so with conventional software the user
interface acts as sort of this natural
seam for designers and engineers to
coordinate and given their differences
in expertise
you know boundary abstractions and
separation of concern is actually
favored to make the process more
efficient that is designers don't
typically share like low level details
about their interview notes or
observation notes or their prototype
alternatives with engineers similarly
engineers are not required or they don't
share like how they implement the
software or details about the code and
framework with designers
while this is great for conventional
software design it becomes problematic
for designing human ai experiences
specifically
the abstraction boundaries between
designers and engineers kind of
introduces this knowledge blindness that
is when creating these core ai
capabilities engineers don't have a full
understanding of the human task model or
their interaction model or what they
expect the ai to do
and what ends up happening is they end
up building all these capabilities that
may not really align with what people
want in this example on
analyzing videos one of the participants
says like you know people would just go
off and bear directions get obsessed
with trying to identify guns or
something that really wasn't important
to what we were doing
similarly uh the designers experience
technology blindness that is they they
don't fully understand like the
capabilities and limitations of these
different ai sub components and there's
either like under trust or over trust in
what ai can or cannot do
an example would be like the the twitter
image auto cropping example where there
was no interface
effort and for them to manually crop
these images
and as you can see here
with conventional software the designers
are used to building like these screen
to screen flows but with ai the
probability space is much more widely
open they need to understand the failure
cases the confidence and how to deal
with confidence scores and thresholds
second
because of these boundaries designers
and engineers tend to work rather
independently which which leads to sort
of like
committing or concretizing their design
choices even before they align the ai
and ux and this leads to a lot of
friction at the boundaries
so with
like i mentioned in the earlier example
of the phone unlock thing the designer
creates these final specifications
before handing off to the engineers but
that becomes problematic in this case so
one of the engineers comments about this
saying like you know they would just
hand off these design documents to the
engineer and say implement this it felt
particularly extraneous when it got very
granular and it was not the best medium
to describe the desired behavior
similarly engineers also like you know
finalize you spend months building these
machine learning models and then go to
the designers and say hey can you find a
place to integrate this into your
product and that doesn't work either so
in this case like um i think the team
was working on some kind of a taxonomy
for classifying videos so they would
build this whole thing and go to the
designer and say hey find a place to put
this into like a voice assistant in this
case so they have their own taxonomy on
what kind of information they're looking
for but for users it doesn't work
response
and the third problem is like these
boundaries rustic collaboration really
because designers and engineers don't
know the process about like designers
don't understand the engineering process
engineers don't know a lot about like
the design process which means it's hard
for them to identify opportunities to
work with each other or to give inputs
or collaborate
so in one example we had a designer say
like it seemed very odd to me that as
designers we were not invited to the
data annotation sessions so we had to
invite ourselves just to talk to the
domain experts
for engineers that approach us more like
the machine is going to figure it out we
could be talking about health or
elephants in a circus and it's all the
same to them
and the same problem happens on the
other side as well where designers have
their own priorities and are focused on
like products and end users which means
they're not incentivized to really work
on these
core ai effort that goes on
so what ends up happening in a lot of
these organizations is an ai first
design workflow that is you have machine
learning engineers and researchers
creating these new ai capabilities and
then asking designer product teams to
integrate this into the product
and as we've seen as an example in the
gender shades paper if we discover after
the fact that these models don't work
for certain subgroups of population not
only will it require costly rework to
fix these issues but people are already
harmed
so
in in addition like we also saw that you
know some teams yes
so
in that case like are the gender shapes
how would
involving ux design earlier have solved
that problem versus just
the engineers didn't do their job of
making sure that the you know vision
systems they were doing worked across
the population yes but uh also like
thinking about the representativeness of
data that is something that ux teams
could have supported them with but isn't
this the thing we should expect
engineers to do independent of ux design
uh i'm arguing no no yeah i'm saying
designers should be involved in efforts
and
i wouldn't argue that designers
shouldn't be involved early in any
project but i also feel like there's
some level that we should expect
engineering
to understand how technology is used
yeah um yeah i will i will get to this
at a later point
so we also noticed that you know teams
that were successful in actually doing
this they practice deliberate leaky
abstractions at the boundaries that
allow them to sort of collaborate and
work with each other
and what i mean by that is rather than
observing like these strict boundaries
and separation of consents successful
teams
created these a number of these ad hoc
representational objects and shared it
with each other that would expose low
level design and implementation details
with each other and through these
abstraction leaks they were actually
able to you know engage in like
knowledge communication uh
design negotiation as well as even like
co-design and evaluation
so leaky abstractions firstly like they
alleviate knowledge blindness which i
mentioned earlier
so in a lot of cases what we noticed
were these designers rather than you
know doing the whole like user research
to this final design specifications they
would create these initial
envisioning visualizations of sorts and
sketches and storyboards and share them
with the engineering team to kind of
help them think about like
you know
how they should be planning out the ai
design space
and similarly the the ai product teams
when they think about these new ai
capabilities rather than waiting until
the end they would uh usually this a
university intends to do this they
create these small
prototypes and then share them with the
designers and ask them to play around
with it to kind of help them understand
how machine learning can actually be
beneficial in specific use cases so as
this person says like we got something
tangible enough that we could go and
actually talk to the designer and be
like here's what we were thinking it
also broke the problem down such that
the designers understand here's the
benefit of where machine learning can be
applied
and further these abstraction leaks
promote design collaboration so instead
of people working on their respective
designs and silo
they can actually start to
bring in engineers in creating like
these ui prototypes so in this example
this designer was making like a wizard
of ours prototype of a model and then
they worked with the data scientists to
get the model output who also like
explained the reasoning behind these
things how the different weights were
set and how these productions happen and
they use this to kind of then share with
end users to get their feedback
and similarly the engineers reported
things like they find
artifacts like storyboards very helpful
which is not true in like the previous
case um so you know here is a situation
and like this is what should happen over
the course of this interaction it's
really useful to have back and forth
with people who are trained to think
carefully about these experiences
and lastly leaky abstractions support
evaluation of design like early on in
the process before waiting until
a final product is developed and
deployed so in this case we noticed
instances in which like engineers would
take like the outputs of machine
learning models as spreadsheets and then
talk to either legal experts to kind of
walk them through what's going on under
the hood or share these outputs with
domain experts who would then like
label whether like the outputs and
predictions are
right or wrong and then they would use
that feedback to kind of revise on their
models
and
these prototypes are also helpful in
like evaluating the product with target
end users as well so they would create
these different prototypes with uh you
know
visualizations about explainability and
then uh especially when they are like
comparing different algorithms so in
this case they were working on this
image
based search system so they created
around like 20 different versions of the
algorithm and each time they would
create these explainable visualizations
of the palettes with the original image
and the target and compare them uh or
like get feedback from the end users
so in this way we saw like a number of
these
unconventional
you know boundary negotiation objects
that were shared between designers and
engineers throughout this ai workflow
to communicate about user needs for
training data designers would create
like qualitative code books and share
those with labelers and engineers or
communicating user needs for behavior
where they would
like i mentioned earlier share user
scenarios low fetility prototypes
provide ground to data and usage reports
and also
invite the engineers into like user
evaluation so that they could see
firsthand like what's going on
similarly engineers also share things
like computational notebooks with
designers to kind of help them play
around with the data to kind of
assess it for like representativeness
and so on or communicate model behavior
through these envisioning grey box
prototypes
share raw model outputs and create these
dashboards
and
they also shared like you know these
prototypes that would allow designers to
kind of evaluate
and gather feedback on their own
so based on these findings we see that
leaky abstractions offer sort of an
alternative to an ai first design
workflow
that is instead of first creating the ai
and then like trying to integrate it to
the product team what we saw that
successful teams are doing is like they
would create fuzzy or partial
specifications of both the ai and the ui
and then by sharing these artifacts
through leaky abstractions with each
other like the design decision and
design details they were able to
collaboratively assess negotiate and
revise their own design
for example like an engineer would
create like a
share like an evolving ai behavior with
the design team who would then evaluate
that end users and provide feedback and
not committing to the design at this
early stage makes it more pliable for
collaboration and inputs
and
across like these successive iterations
more and more aspects of the design
becomes finalized and the need for
leakiness reduces and in the final
stages you have a product which is
aligned across ai ui and humans
so
with this first uh work we kind of saw
that like instead of yes
you know in your first abstraction where
you just have this complete line you
have design and engineering
um
when
you add in ai i'm wondering if another
issue becomes just more communication
because i've noticed in some companies
instead of just having back end
engineering and front engineer now you
also have a machine learning team and
yeah and so the ui people
like a lot of things are like
oh the back end people say that's the
machine learning people's job and the
machine learning people say oh no it's
the back end people so there's like this
more kind of passing the buck which is
harder for the ux did you see yeah
this is a bit of a simplified
representation but this applies to many
different roles including like data
scientists domain experts like in-house
like clinicians especially like in
healthcare application and like the the
point i wanted to make was like uh
instead of like one a workflow which is
more linear where one person comes to
the design and like throws it over the
wall now you have different people like
sharing the kind of design decisions
they're making which allows them to sort
of realign or adjust their own design
and sort of more collaboratively rather
than coordinating
so one of the limitations of this first
project was because of nda reasons like
these companies couldn't give us a lot
of low level details about like what
they were doing or how this
collaboration happened so
to get a better sense of like what's
going on through these like shared
artifacts we did a second study where
we brought in people to the lab and
asked them to work together to design an
ai application
so
this was an in-lab design study with
around 20 participants we had like 10 ui
designers 10 ai engineers
and they worked in pairs to kind of
come up with a solution to a design
problem and we conducted 10 sessions in
total
we gave them a very simple problem we
told them like you know can you build an
ai powered application to declutter the
photo album
the problem domain is simple enough that
everyone understands like we said like
you know people are taking lots and lots
of photos on their phones not all of
them are useful so can you find a way to
like use ai to declutter this and also
like computer vision and image data
offers like this rich design space to
think about how to solve this problem
and
based on the findings from the first
study about like sharing these um
user data and user personas we created a
set of what we're calling data personas
where we have like these four different
personas about an artist a parent
an instagram influencer and a corporate
traveler but we also gave them like
these um the last 15 photos taken by
each of these people to kind of help
them think about like how they might
declutter the photo album
and again we use the design guidelines
that these companies are putting up to
develop a protocol this is a very
simplified version but the paper has of
the full details the idea was that they
would first work together to brainstorm
ways in which
ai can support decluttering the photo
album
then they brainstormed how they would
implement those behaviors uh using like
ai including things like deciding
features and
was that a question
no uh and then they would prototype the
user uh interface for ai and specify the
model apis between the interface and the
model's inputs and outputs and then
designed for ais uncertainties including
like error handling explainability
failure and expectations
we we use qualitative coding to
analyze this data so
the main finding i want to share with
you is around this idea of like the the
data we gave with each of the person as
that is the images they acted as this
content common ground for designers and
engineers to collaborate
they both have like different domain and
expertise they have different processes
they follow and different things they
design but then we saw that this end
user data from each of the personas
acted as like an anchor point for them
to ideate on these designs
what we're calling as like data probes
as a tool for design
and what i mean by that is like starting
with this idea of like ai and the
abstract like we know i told them what
ai behavior we want we didn't tell them
like um filter images that are not high
quality or any of that we just told them
like use the ai to declutter the photos
so using this individual data points
from each of the personas they started
generating user scenarios about like why
um people may have cluttered photo
albums and using those scenarios they
kind of thought about different ai
behaviors like you know
when when we should detect and delete
the photo like as soon as they capture
it at a later point of time should we
aggregate it and things like that
so in this example like you know the
parent persona like he's taken multiple
duplicate photos of us fidgety kids and
like so they talk about like any i
identify duplicate photos and find the
best one to keep
and then the engineer goes like yes we
can cluster images based on similarity
so once you have this behavior that you
want in this case like identifying say
duplicate photos then you need to think
about how you're going to implement like
what does duplicate mean for different
personas
so to do that again like using the
scenarios and the data points these
teams engaged in what i'm calling
cognitive walkthroughs with the data and
ai behavior to define these uh specific
implementation details
so in this case um
they talk about like can i figure out if
there is an image that is significantly
blurrier and then delete those like so
once you have these duplicate photos
then maybe some kind of ranking by
quality like blurriness lighting uh they
even talk about like eyes closed uh face
and object detection and so on
and they also use these data points to
identify things they should not do so in
one of the teams they were thinking
about like deleting photos in which
people were not smiling and then the
designer goes like if someone had a
stroke and they're not smiling deleting
those photos would be bad and then the
engineer says like you know the model
might predict that she's not smiling
because of missing two of the braces
[Applause]
and once you have this implementation
the next thing is to determine like what
inputs should be provided and what
outputs uh you should return to the
interface
and they
they brainstormed on like what the api
should look like by creating user
interface prototypes based on these
implementation again this was an
iterative process where the designers
would actually use the thumbnail images
we gave them for each of the personas so
instead of using like uh placeholder
text and images we asked them to use the
actual data and creating these
prototypes
so here they kind of identify like you
know if they had a large cluster of
photos can we cluster them based on the
reasons and then they start to think
about explainability and like how do we
assign a reason for why your photo is
being deleted and the engineer kind of
explains uh how it works internally and
like how do we assign different ways to
different regions and should we
return just the top
reason for deleting a photo or not
so
based on these findings we propose this
initial process model for co-creating ai
experiences now rather than like an ai
first or a ui first workflow
the this model kind of distributes
agency between designers and engineers
designers can use their data personas
their ai infused scenarios expectation
models and interface prototype to shape
the ai's design and implementation and
api without having technical details and
then
the our approach also shifts sort of the
engineer's mindset towards a more
proactive engagement and human centered
design process
and then
using the individual data points teams
can engage in like divergent design
thinking and mutually constrained
convergence towards a solution
now uh the the the approach that we used
in this initial session is fine for like
you know the first uh brainstorming kind
of session but as the the fidelity of
the data and the complexity of the model
increases as people start building they
can no longer use this pen and paper
approach but then like the model that we
propose can be used to think about like
what kind of tools people might need and
supporting these different
collaborations at different stages of
the development process
so i'm going to present you like one
example where we built this prototyping
tool based on the findings from this lab
study
as i mentioned like prototyping with
real data and machine learning models
allow the designers to sort of
experience the ai's output and
capabilities firsthand as they are
building this
but if you look at conventional ui
prototyping tools they kind of look like
this which is essentially like a closed
box uh view but you only put in like
placeholder text and images and so on
and if the designers are going to like
you know explore the model on their
first hand or see what the outputs look
like they may have to work with
different tools for model exploration
and evaluation
so with prototype our intent was to see
how we can like combine this model
exploration
user interface prototyping and
evaluation within a single workflow that
we're calling model inform prototyping
and we developed this tool called proto
ai to support this
prototyping workflow and i'll give you a
quick walkthrough of this tool at a high
level the tool has four main tabs uh the
first tab is a collection of machine
learning models and services and then
you have this data tab where you can
like gather user inputs and data and
like run the model with those data as
part of your prototyping process and
then you have the the standard ui
prototyping tab and then there's a tab
for evaluating your different prototypes
let me walk you through this tool by
taking this very simple example of
imagine you're building an application
where you input an image and then
the the model classifies and outputs a
label for that this is similar to like a
lot of applications we see
uh with
things like the birder app where you can
recognize species of birds by inputting
an image
so to build to prototype this experience
the designer would first go and select
the image classification model and go to
the data tab
here they can upload like a csv file of
birds they have already collected along
with some ground true data
and using this input they can actually
run the model
and over here the model returns like
three different outputs with a different
confidence score for each label
now once they have this they can then go
to the ui tab and start to incorporate
like this the input data that they
collected along with the model output
directly in their prototyping process
so you have the the standard user
interface controls like a text box and
label and things like that
but you also have this data elements tab
where you can you know drop in like the
photo of the actual bird and also like
the label that the model retained
and once you do this you can
if you go to the data previews tab now
you see what the interface looks like
for all of the input data that you had
in the data tab and because you supplied
ground truth label proto ai
automatically tags erroneous instances
uh with errors which you can go and like
debug and analyze so in this case i
think they're like three instances where
the label that the model returned does
not match the label that the designer
inputted that's ground truth
then now
okay one thing i forgot to mention was
like the labels that had errors the
confidence scores were less than 60.
so now what they can do is they can
start to oh actually
yes so what the designer is doing here
is they also add the confidence code and
they can and this is meant for them to
debug so that they can go look at like
what's going on in these areas instances
and this is where like the confidence
score for instances for the confidence
score is less than 60 like the
the model is it doesn't perform very
well or it's an error so now they can go
and start to implement like mixed
initiative design where
they can create a new interface state
and add a condition where if the
classification accuracy is like less
than 60 then you show this new state
so over here instead of just showing one
label they can return all of the labels
but also let the end user enter their
own label if they choose to
and with this if you go back to the
previous tab now you can see that for
instance which have like
errors it shows the new state so this
kind of lets the designer play around
with
these different model outputs and set
thresholds and design different states
of the interface for different types of
uncertainties
and the designer can also like because
they have the raw model output they can
think about presentation aspects like
the api like what format should the
model return the output should it be
like a numerical score or whether do you
want to categorize it into high medium
low so like these are things that the
designer now has the flexibility to work
directly in based on what the interface
needs are
so here i'm just
you know adding a categorical
column with high or low based on the
accuracy score
and then in addition like you know if
you have multiple data points on a
screen you can actually set the data
context of the screen instead of having
like one image over here i'm seeing all
of the images for a persona
and we have these widgets that um
help you present like explainable output
so like this is the best photo and these
are the other three options and things
like that and
so in in summary like with protoei the
designer can kind of leverage the full
advantage of like this vertical
prototyping starting with raw data
running the model output and evaluating
and designing iteratively they can
supply their input data
directly make use of the features and
model outputs
if there is ground true data they can
also use that to compare what the model
is doing and create these derived
columns and using this they can kind of
facet the data in different ways and
create different interface states based
on different kinds of ai errors
and you can imagine something like this
being used to evaluate the twitter's
biased image cropping issue where the
designer could have taken like the
saliency uh image model and then like
inputted like different data with
different salient points and um test it
for how well the algorithm performs or
if you want to do something like netflix
movie recommendation you can think of
supplying input data with different
personas and with different prior
history of what kind of movies they
watch and that can be used to sort of
prototype like learnability or learning
over time
and as i showed today you can think of
creating like these mixed initiative
designs such as ambiguity widgets
so
so far like in this talk i hope i've
convinced you that rather than like an
ai first approach where the engineer
just hands off this black box viewer
close box model to the designer we can
you know rather take a more
collaborative approach where the ai and
ui components are sort of designed and
parallel um so building on this work i
am interested in continuing to think
about like these different layers and
this in this application stack
uh the thing which i'm currently working
on is in thinking about like this idea
of like data personas and how they can
inform the training data for these
machine learning models and i know
there's some paddle work going on at
stanford around like data center ki i
still don't have a clear understanding
of what that is but hopefully this will
converge at some point
so right now if you look at machine
learning textbook it's usually like
acquire an initial data set and then
there's some work on thinking about like
how do we document and like make the the
data characteristics more transparent
for other users or like in analyzing the
data we already have
but what i'm interested in is and seeing
how we can bring together all these
different people with different
expertise to kind of define these data
personas which can then inform the
training data needs
and in
the ai model and behavior space i'm very
much interested in thinking about how do
we measure performance and this is a bit
of a challenging problem
so currently if you think of like a
speech recognition thing like the the
way you measure performance is like word
at a rate but that doesn't really
capture things like demographics
sociocultural context resource
availability and policy and regulation
so i'm interested in seeing how people
with different expertise can come
together in defining fair performance
metrics and what kind of tools do we
need to support this collaboration
process
and lastly i'm interested in extending
some of the work which we've done in
proto ai to think about
explainability and how do we bring in
end users in identifying some of the
errors so in the current version where
you have the data previous tab it's
mainly the designer who looks for these
errors but in some cases the designers
may not know i cannot say like whether
it's an error or not so i'm interested
in seeing how we can bring in end users
and what kind of explainable support
they may need to
debug this
design on their own
but more broadly like in addition to
thinking about like how do we support
expertise and collaboration and what
kind of tools we may need i also do a
lot of work on
designing these interactive intelligence
systems using ai specifically for human
learning creativity and sense making
right now i have started some new
conversations and projects around
thinking about ai literacy for k through
learning in the wild that is learning
outside classroom settings like how we
can take what we know from best
practices and learning in the classroom
and e-learning and apply them to more
open-ended setting and i'm also
interested in science communication
through visualizations and text so if
you're a master student or an undergrad
looking to work on research projects
please please please reach out to me
and with that i will take questions
[Applause]
yes
so it's proto ai
that evaluation tab maybe i missed it
it's mainly about evaluating the model
uh evaluating and not doing like a user
test and so i'm wondering
like you need to do both in a real
prototyping tool so i'm wondering how
would you imagine adding that capability
and how you look at that data
versus the model data like they're
intermittent yeah like that would be a
way to
understand it
yes
so like the
thing which i'm thinking right now is
around this idea of like error driven
design like in this case like you have
these designers who bring in their own
data and try to evaluate the the
interface layout and design for these
models and what um evidences they should
provide in terms of explainability and
things but i am interested in seeing how
we can take this tool and like give it
to end users who can then supply their
own input data sort of like the
click-through prototype uh but but users
inputting their own data and like the
model running and then they're able to
like annotate their different outputs
sort of as a feedback but that's a good
question and i'm still thinking about
how to bring in what we know from like
user testing and what kind of um
how do we measure like uh usability and
things like that into proto ai
yeah you focused on the design process
but the uh the product life cycle
there's also monitoring and maintenance
and improvement and there's issues of
drift in the data or in the user needs
could this process be extended
throughout the product lifecycle um
that is a good question um the thing is
the answer is yes because a lot of these
models are designed to learn and adapt
and evolve over time a little bit of
stuff we've done is like demonstrating
how you can test this up front
with the netflix example i talked about
um but it would be interesting to see
like how you know what practitioners do
in terms of like collecting these system
usage logs and how they sort of revise
their model um
yeah
yes
how and what is fritto ai's licensing
model
right now it's a research pipe
uh that was my question
i'm just curious what the status of it
was is it planning to become like a
public company or
uh we are trying to find ways to
commercialize it but
as of right now it's just an academic
research prototype
yes
so a lot of the examples you used
used uh vision or image examples
wondering if um you were using other
domains such as like speech or other
like
your thoughts on how
that would change yeah i am interested
in text as well like and i've built a
few systems using text and machine
learning so i'm interested in seeing how
like i don't if you're talking about the
process of like proto ai i don't think
that would change much
but obviously like the the kind of
augmentation or like visualizations you
support for text is going to be very
different um
chin yang who is now a faculty at
cornell like they have done some work on
like conversational interfaces and
sketching natural language processing
along with collaborators at microsoft so
i think in the future it would be
interesting to see how we can bring in
some of like their findings into it to
electrode ai
how do you extend this uh when the user
is doing like e-shot learning like where
they have to give a few examples and the
model will customize that
um so the way we are doing it right now
is like when you supply the initial
input data you can kind of facet the
data by different people and how much
data they provide but it would be
interesting to see how we can extend
this for more cases in the future like
at this point we were just interested in
seeing like there's no tool that does
this vertical end-to-end prototyping now
like it's usually like the interface
prototyping and everything else is like
a closed box separate thing but i i
agree there are like many ways in which
water ai can be extended to support
different
ai experience design use cases
have you thought about how you use
multiple models at once because i didn't
really get that in the
interface and then more importantly
a beyond kind of similar to the other
question how do i get the multi-modal
uh interfaces or is this really just for
kind of gui interfaces that um
so right now we do support multiple
models like i selected just one model
but you can select multiple over here
and it would have like what we're
calling a simplified model card for each
of these um so you can actually leverage
multiple features into the design but i
haven't thought about like multi-model
inputs yet it's right now just like a ui
igui prototyping tool
yes
[Music]
oh oh hi um yeah thank you for talking
yeah i'm julia currently a research
intern with professor james landing so
um it's also about the proto ai so i
think i guess it's still a bit like um
engineering driven because currently
it's based on working prototypes like
working models for example here like
image classification is a pretty
develop tasks but what if the design
team is given design to something that's
you know the engineering team is still
working on like still researching and
doesn't have a prototype that works very
well great question um the way we
support that is you don't need to have
like this model to be able to use
produce so you can imagine in the
scenario you're talking about where the
designer gets in the input data and they
manually create what the behavior has to
be like for each of the center data so
they can just upload the whole thing as
a spreadsheet and once they figure out
like what works and they can share this
to the engineers they're going to
communicate like the behavior or design
concept so
having them a working model is not a
requirement to use this prototyping
workflow
so in your future work you mentioned
about involving more stakeholders in
data creation and also to define
performance metric yeah i wonder how
does your finding in design and
engineering team
and also the process model
being extended to the scenario
yeah so i i think again that like um
what i'm interested in is in seeing like
what kind of leaky abstractions can
support this kind of collaboration so if
you think of like the data visualization
community like you have a lot of these
tools that would allow visualization
designers to create data sets with
certain statistical properties to help
them like think through like these
visualizations and we have some stuff
around like i don't know if you've seen
like this app with generates like faces
based on like certain parameters so i'm
interested in seeing like what kind of
queries will we need from all these
different experts to generate like
synthetic data sets for like training
the ai or for evaluating these behavior
but a lot of this would revolve around
like leaky abstractions and the types of
representations that multiple people can
use
one example is in some of our design
sessions we had like the interviews we
had these machine learning engineers who
would once they have some data and a
working model then they would sit with
the legal expert and then talk about
like this is the data we need and this
is what it does and then in some cases
where there's a disagreement then they
would think about like what else can you
use to do this instead of collecting
this data so i think like having those
kind of conversations up front and
thinking about these data probes is um
the direction i'm thinking
yeah nice kind of on a so great talk
on kind of a related note i'm wondering
um about your you know future work in
terms of data personas and a little bit
on what you touched here and i guess you
know some of the concerns in the design
field around personas in terms of there
being a lot of bias and
challenges there and i'm wondering you
know what are your thoughts on how do
you address those that like yeah data
personas as a potential source of bias
as well in terms of reading these yeah
um i think like the way i'm thinking
about it is like do by involving these
multiple stakeholders is eventually to
have like a more representative set like
like you said like if you had just one
person a person like making these
personas it's obviously going to be
biased and limited in scope so i'm
trying to see like if you can like
crowdsource or curate like a set of data
personas from different people different
geographies and
backgrounds to kind of create a more
comprehensive set which can then be used
across different application domains
thanks
nice well i think then uh let's think
hari and yeah